morning welcome back those of you who
are with us yesterday welcome to those
who are here for the first time this
morning it really I don't have a long
speech because i think as you'll note
from the program and as we experience
yesterday there's a lot to talk about
that will come from the speakers and the
discussion and i hope very much that we
can continue the the dialogue often
intense discussions that that developed
yesterday and the kind of and continue
to respond further to the wonderful talk
last night by Mark Princeton so I you
know just by way of opening this first
panel I wanted to note that you will
note or you know kind of confirmed that
you will have will note that there is a
certain let's a cultural constellation
that is represented a series of
transactions in in and across the sort
of spanish-speaking Atlantic let's say
from between Spain Latin America and the
United States Spanish english-speaking
Atlantic that that could be understood
and maybe the title the US advance
through architecture in the quest for
identity might buy us a little bit a
little bit this way as as a kind of
story about Americanization or about
like the Americans in relation to
everybody else and
you know you'll see some of this and the
details but i think our speakers have in
a way something else to offer that that
marks something that i was trying to at
least tease out a little bit yesterday
in the discussion it marks this this
strange and complicated relation that is
figured in let's say the hyphen between
nation and state as as they might be
considered together and in in
correspondence and often in dissonance
often violently in in historical context
that we've been exploring so here you
know perhaps we can we can guard against
the the sort of narratives of
Americanization with which we may be a
bit more familiar particularly in a
so-called post-war period again a
complete misnomer as we again as we
heard already yesterday there's nothing
post-war about this but so so the in
other words to guard against the idea of
a kind of meta state a super-state or
super nation that that determines who's
who sort of interest in practices and so
on if it's logical terms whose
narratives whose discourses those
institutions organize everything else
what could be substituted in the place
of that narrative might be something to
consider that is I think in a sense the
provocation of the framing of this this
this is titled it was even ironic title
of the of the panel itself so so that's
a kind of invitation as we listen to the
three very interesting papers which I
have had a chance to read and enjoy and
I'm sure you will as well to try to make
some connections and think relationally
in a sense as the papers themselves
invite us to do as well so without
further ado I will simply introduce the
speakers to you all at once and and then
allow them to to present their paper we
will
begin with Brett Tippie who is working
this PhD at the escuela técnica superior
dr. Cora at the Universidad de Navarra
in Pamplona and Brett's paper is titled
modern living in a totalitarian state
Richard nitra in Spain 1956 he'll be
followed by Maria preto also from the
escuela técnica superior dr. Torah also
affiliated and working on her PhD
through that institution in Navarra and
Maria's paper will be is titled writing
the Spanish transition to democracy as
AZ CA Madrid Europe and then finally
Anna really on who is working on her PhD
at the School of Architecture and
planning at the MIT will introduce us to
the meanderings osa of certain company
Sarah goes south so with with that I
welcome again our three speakers and all
of you and look forward to to what
promises to be a wonderful panel and a
wonderful part two to this conference
first of all I would like to thank
Columbia University and the the
organizing committee for the opportunity
to come and present some of the research
than working on currently and without
further ado I'll get started in the
post-war period the progress of Spanish
architecture was a road of obstacles
doing part to an externally imposed
isolation most of the world's
governments refused to recognize
Franco's totalitarian regime and
maintained little or no relations with
it thereby delaying the already late
arrival of new ideas and technologies
and forcing Spain to face the task of
post-war reconstruction largely on its
own this external isolation finally
loosened when the United States began to
consider the regime as an important
anti-communist ally by signing the 1953
Madrid packed the u.s. formally paved
the way for nap for normalized
international relations with the Spanish
regime the pact guaranteed economic and
military aid for Spain in return for
Spain's willingness to host US military
installations which were eventually
constructed in virtually every major
region of Spain the US Air Force
perceived the Iberian Peninsula as a
strategic location in the fight against
communism and quickly mobilize the
construction of air bases in der decken
dr-dos just outside of Madrid Saragossa
and civilian for Spain the fast pace of
construction of these large-scale
projects represented a crucial
opportunity for post-war technological
advancement in january of 1955 the
madrid journal inform instead of
construction promoted this advance to a
wide Spanish audience by publishing a
monographic issue on modern construction
techniques of airports and air base
facilities with specific articles in
such topics as terminals hangars runways
control towers and military air bases
one of these articles which we see the
first page of here on the screen and was
written by Commander Libby washborn
civil engineer and
director of facilities of the US Air
Force originally titled originally
published under the title planning and
engineering of US air bases however it
was recognizing the articles potential
to educate their readers on modernized
construction techniques the Spanish
editors opted for the more instructional
title a como se porto yet de una vez a
area which translates as how to design
an air base in addition to the didactic
account of the specific technical
engineering problems the article also
outlined the fundamentals of the more
architectural topics of harmony with the
landscape community centers site
selection and recommendations for the
design of air force personnel housing
the imminent influx of thousands of US
Air Force pilots officers and other
personnel who would operate these bases
not to mention the spouses and children
they would bring with them cause the US
Air Force to convene a complete a
competition for the design of Air Force
family housing in Spain in February 1956
this competition called for the design
of four residential neighborhoods
veritable cities in their own rights for
the exclusive use of US air force
personnel one in 30 home they are those
just outside of Madrid one in Zaragoza
one in moron de la frontera in Sevilla
and one in San Pablo also in civilian in
addition to the externally imposed
isolation that the Madrid packed and the
construction of US military bases helped
to break the much more serious blow to
the progress of architecture and
post-war Spain came from within
widespread post-war rationalism
nationalism created a one-party
totalitarian architectural system in
which modern architecture was deemed
essentially incompatible with the more
widely preferred Spanish tradition we
saw this very clearly innocent fiancee
paper yesterday and perhaps this general
rejection of modern architecture was
most eloquently expressed in 1940 by the
architect the Spanish architect Luis
muga who described Spain's pre-war a
brief pre-war experimentation with
modern architecture
as the and I quote the latest rabble of
scum originating in the cubism and
rationalism of alico bruce yet the
Bauhaus and all the Jews of the world
end quote however in spite of such in
spite of such xenophobic tendencies in
the late 1940s and early 1950s Spain and
Spain's intentionally imposed
architectural totalitarianism began to
break down as Spanish architects
increasingly appropriated modern ideas
in the reconstruction and modernization
of their country in an article that
represents a key moment in this
transition our Spanish architect
Francisco science the otha proclaimed
that and I quote to deny today in 1952
the victory of this new architectural
adventure and its promises more than its
victory is to deny the light of day and
quote science Theresa illustrated this
argument with photographs of several
buildings designed by Richard Neutra
there by introducing nitra to the
post-war readership and promoting his
work as a modern archetype and we see
here the the nitrous Wilkins house used
on the cover of that on that the cover
of that issue interestingly enough never
indicating that nature is the author of
that house such promotion of an
ethnically jewish and unabashedly no
excuse me him yes such promotion of an
ethnically jewish and unabashedly modern
architect in the mid twentieth century
Spanish press represents an undeniable
reversal of the internally imposed
isolationism projected by Luis Moya and
others during the early post-war period
in regards to Franco himself some
historians have suggested that unlike
his German and Italian counterparts he
held a rather nonchalant our attitude
towards architecture whether or not this
is true it is clear that the
stipulations of the Madrid pact
specifically in the case of the of the
1956 competition and the program of the
competition required Franco to
relinquish all architectural control
over the competition however in this
project not only did Franco function as
hands-off dictator he also functioned as
the hands tied dictator the final choice
of design of the basis for the final
choice of design for the basis appears
to have been made by a jury composed of
five members of the US Air Force without
representation of Spanish architects
whether officially associated with the
regime or otherwise moreover the land on
which the bases were constructed was not
owned or seated by the Spanish state
rather the competition program
stipulated that the neighborhoods were
to be financed constructed maintained
and managed by a private individual
concern or group of of concerns on
privately owned land in turn this
private spanish consortium would lease
the property to the US Air Force there
for Franco's participation in the
competition was minimal if existent
clearly by the time of nitrous arrival
in 1956 Spanish architect such as McAfee
sac Francisco Cabrera jose antonio
boudic and jose maria sorceress had
already produced several important and
highly modern works there for nitrous
contribution to the competition cannot
be considered can cannot be interpreted
as the first light of modern
architecture in Spain nonetheless nitra
did intend the 1956 project to become a
model of modern living particularly
relevant for post-war Spain in a lecture
he gave at the escuela de arquitectura
in Madrid in November 1954 nitra opposed
the self-pity and traditionalist
rejections fundamental to the internal
architectural isolationism for years
Spaniards had cited their lack of
industrialization and financial
resources as obstructions to the
development of modern architecture in
Spain however in this discourse nature
dismissed such excuses by declaring that
the aims of modern architecture can
indeed be achieved even within limited
financial and industrial resources and
here in the image you see Reuters
Macintosh house which was published in
1955 by the the revista de nadie de
arquitectura and specifically the
caption on this on this house highlights
the construction in wood the
the very cheap materials and the very
quick and easy construction process he
also asserted that the modern
architecture did not necessarily have to
be seen as running contrary to tradition
rather and especially in the case of
Spain he argued that he started that it
should be note it should be rooted in
the deep traditions and spirit of the
culture that creates and inhabits it
also during his 1954 visit nitra gave a
lecture entitled architecture as the
human factor in which he discredited the
traditionalist idea that modern
architecture is inevitably inhuman then
less than two years later who might
reduce the 1956 competition to prove
these points in so doing he became the
only international modern master who
directly and personally addressed
Spain's peculiar post-war difficulties
with a specific architectural solution
in order to propose a modern
architecture viable in post-war Spain
noite reproduce the design that was
economically sustainable in order to
reduce long-term operational costs he
studied Spain's climate to provide an
efficient architectural response
although he found that his original
assumptions about Spain's warm
Mediterranean summers were true he was
surprised to find that the winters even
in Andalusia can be harsh and cold in a
letter to Robert Alexander written after
his visit to Seville in February of 1956
he remarked that and I quote it was
terribly cold in Andalusia and not at
all southern or subtropical and quote in
addition to the programmatic
requirements this discovery led him to
design housing for for a climate that
has both Mediterranean and continental
aspects he provided each building with a
uniform north-south orientation in order
to take advantage of the winter Sun and
minimize the adverse effects of rain
prevailing winds and summer heat while
admitting that this uniform orientation
would require increased topographic
modification there by supposing a higher
initial construction cost nature argued
that it would be more economically
viable in the long-term maintenance and
here in the image you can see the site
plan for the more
and a la frontera a base outside of
Savita with all of the all of the the
residences facing north and south
furthermore on several occasions nature
investigated the maximum allowable rent
proposed for the individual residential
units by the US Air Force in order to
keep his design within those strict
limits his design also kept in mind the
fact that apart from the obligatory rent
the airmen were also responsible for
paying the utility bills electricity
water heating oil etc this additional
cost charged directly to the tenant
further persuaded him to orient the
housing to take advantage of natural
heating and cooling strategies thereby
reducing the financial strain on the
airmen nature also argued that modern
architecture should indeed could indeed
be achieved in Spain despite the
country's delayed industrialization as
evidence his 1956 housing was designed
to be constructed without cutting edge
technology or highly skilled labor it's
specific it specified simple and locally
available construction construction
materials such as native burned clay
brick as used in all parts of Spain
stucco Spanish floor tile terrazzo and
tile roofs these materials were then to
be assembled according to local
construction practices perhaps the
greatest design challenge that nitro
faced in this project was the
requirement for design to design for a
dual cultural clientele the program
established that the housing would be
rented by the US Air Force personnel
from a spa private Spanish consortium
during an initial period of seven years
at which time the rental agreement would
either be renewed or terminated
predicting the EDD the eventual transfer
of all housing units to Spanish
facilities who would eventually Spanish
families who would eventually purchase
them directly from the private Spanish
consortium the program required the
architects to design modern housing that
met with both american and spanish
cultural expectations noi choi was
uniquely prepared to for such a task due
to the lessons he learned while working
for frank lloyd wright the three decades
he had lived among
designing housing for Americans and his
lifelong study of the pan Hispanic
culture specifically the program
required the architects to follow
typical high-class Spanish suburban
architecture with floor plans modified
to allow for American living habits
nitra was intrigued by such high class
Spanish cultural norms as month long
vacations in August and pet CMS which
are built in window blinds designed to
completely block out the harsh
Mediterranean Sun and summer heat during
a design meeting with his Spanish
architectural collaborators nitrous son
Dion took note that people go out of
madrid for a month in summer richard who
for the previous two decades had
employed for floor-to-ceiling glazing to
admit natural light into the dwelling
and to seamlessly unite interior and
exterior was understandably anxious
about the programmatic requirement to
include a Tiana's on more than one
occasion he asked questions such as what
are besties honest how are they applied
what size nonetheless his concerns about
the installation and music petty honest
did not prevent moisture from using
large expanses of glass in the project
and incidentally he did include the
betsy honest nature was also fascinated
by the height and by the high spanish
societal custom of employing live in
maids he used the spanish word criada in
a letter to robert alexander he
explained a criada and i quote a criada
gets eight dollars a month but has a
room and bathroom of her own paid in
kind as you see everyone has one
peterson's have to end quote to
accommodate this peculiarly spanish
custom he developed multiple schemes the
first scheme which was not well-received
include one semi-detached dormitory for
every four family units that house for
kadas showing 1 water closet in one
shower is sharing one water closet in
one shower when this idea was not well
received he developed a second and more
accepted scheme that incorporated the
Cree goddess headquarters into the
family home and here you can see an
example of one of the one of the duplex
plans where the corps de yada is is
located up in the upper
and corner however it is perhaps the
programmatic inclusion of exterior but
views in which noise designed most
clearly and simultaneously responded to
both the high class Spanish sensibility
and American living habits recognizing
the patio a courtyard or walled garden
as a traditional element of Spanish
architecture he stated that and I quote
in a Spanish mountain village back toews
supplement a skimpy indoor floor area
and neighbors separated by walls hardly
infringe on each other even without a
roof overhead and quote therefore nitra
not only saw the path you as a
fundamental element of a Spanish home he
also recognized its fundamental
potential to address the higher degree
of seclusion inherent in American living
habits accustomed to the privacy of
single-family homes his American client
would probably have felt uncomfortable
in the month in the medium density
scheme of duplexes and row houses he
proposed for the competition for this
reason noite replaced the blatt the
backyard and setbacks common to the
American residential neighborhoods with
a private patio enclosed by what he
called spur walls he also included
varying at varying vegetation schemes to
soften the spur walls and to
individualize the dwelling units while
it is true that noise are engaged in
this design competition with the
intention of promoting cultural and
economic exchange between the u.s. and
Spain any suggestion that his intentions
were of a political nature would
contradict the facts although this the
competition itself was certainly a
political move nitrous personal
involvement was not perceived as such by
the American officials the Spanish
architectural public or nature himself
admittedly by 1956 he had already
designed to projects for the US federal
government in 1944 he designed a
prototype schools and health centers in
Puerto Rico and in 1955 he designed a
residential neighborhood for the US air
force base in Mountain Home Idaho indeed
the second project represented his first
completed commission for the US Air
Force and provided an unequivocal
precedent for his design
for the residential neighborhoods in
Spain however it was not the US Air
Force who invited nitra to participate
in the competition in Spain in autumn
1955 he received collaboration proposals
from at least two separate Spanish
consortiums first from construcciones
econ econ through class and then from
Emily Aria Alcazar amsa and poor and
purdy who jointly functioned under the
name al Kahf emsa it was the latter
proposal that he eventually accepted
although it is true that nitra the Nitra
propaganda machine never rested to date
no evidence has been found to indicate
that nature himself solicited either of
these two proposals furthermore Dion
nitra architect and collaborator with
his father on various projects including
the 1956 competition speculates that his
father accepted the Commission's solely
on the basis of the international
recognition that would result from and I
quote the sheer volume of housing that
would be constructed in a foreign
country and quote moreover the fact that
the competition jury apparently composed
entirely of American officials did not
award the construction contract to
nitrous team clearly indicates that
nitrous proposal of duplexes and
multi-family row houses did not agree
with either the inherently
individualistic American Dream or its
corresponding political machine finally
the fact that his participation was
solicited by Spaniards and not by any US
official is significant it reveals that
Noah was not acting on behalf of global
Americanization nor was he perceived by
the public in Spain as promoting it
instead it underlines the great respect
held thy Spanish architects for the
Austrian émigré produced largely as a
result of his provocative and entirely
civilian visit to Spain in November of
1954 and reiterated in the subsequent
and exhaustive publication of his works
in the Spanish press although it was
never constructed Richard nitrous 1956
design for housing in Spain helped to
persuade Spanish
text of the feasibility of modern living
within the totalitarian context by using
his own design work as tangible evidence
he avoided political pitfalls and
esoteric arguments and to aid in the
progress of modern architecture in Spain
thank you thank you brett okay and Maria
okay thank you for inviting me for me is
a great happiness over here okay right
in the Spanish transition to democracy
askim and read Europe this is my own
writing of the transition of my country
this paper deals with a long term
concern of mine about the transition to
democracy in my country spain do you see
a spangly title as such it is an
extension of my personal search for the
possibility of democratic consistency in
the production of architecture and
urbanism itself as well as in the
endeavor of building up knowledge by our
cadets base both within and beyond
Spain's frontiers frontiers in the late
1920s mega primo de Rivera dictatorship
enter to crisis at the same time as wall
street cross which didn't help Spain's
international relations with Europe
Spain a Spanish economic life was
restricted from international trade flow
nevertheless sang architects saw the
possibility of internal
internationalization of the country
through the practice of modern
architecture an organism which was
happening in the continent the
international competition of 1929 to the
scientist tension of Madrid brought
aesthetic vehicle of all run economic
growth the avenue of Europe a
representative space for a modern in
Spain in spanning towards the North this
Avenue was a transposition of arturo
soria linear city going through madrid
from south to north known also as poss
in the paseo de Casta jana this space
would become this para mental ground to
introduce and contest modern
architecture and urbanism in Spain and
the successive an opposing political as
the agendas of the state from the Second
Republic to nowadays this is just after
the Civil War and you see here bolivian
song today and the new plan you know if
I can
this is Africa mrs. the gate of urine
the kilt hours the four towers and this
is operation chattering when does the
Spanish transition to democracy take
place where has it being contested or
always contested to what extent was like
a stallion instrumental to the
definition of Spain as a modern state
how this how did this transition or
transitions evolve through this space
and vice versa how was the evolution of
historical interpretation of these
transitions how was the transition to
democracy démocratique imagination in
staying up to date what kind of
democracy I am talking about to splode
these transitions practice and positions
around the pride of the Paseo castellana
I have focus on the figure of a planner
Antonio opinion sir cibrian again did
you see him in the title in addition to
to his work that is hardly ever
discussed the opinion was a Catalan who
was involved in modernizing Madrid
during the Franco's Spain since the mid
victus and until the 70s this paper
traces the oven transformations of the
Madrid michalka restored the European
towards a european capital of the year
2000 along with the yo political
dynamics the world democratization that
came with it this dynamic came to the
stage not without tension the earliest
predictions or in Franco's is paying for
the construction of red Madrid which was
applying to reach a population of 3
million people by the year 2000 made by
Peter Beard Award for his first master
plan of Madrid proof were done between
1944 1946 we're almost contemporary to
the earliest predictions of Europe at
2000 made by Nancy leader Joseph
Goebbels
both wisdom Sonali megalomaniac projects
in the face of our reimagine Europe both
urbanistic alee and financially after
the second world war in his master plan
with a war envisioned a new urban center
for great Madrid and sent to design by
Wiz Mallya as imperialistic a symbol for
Spain this center would have iris
Coriolis style architecture and good
how's business offices especially
designed to compete internationally in
1947 with a girl prepare a new
regulation for this tension of Avenida
de canales among the new name for the
paseo de la castellana advancing a new
vision less traditional for the new
business area the rise of the Iron
Curtain reoriented the role of his
paying international interest the
agreements of the General Assembly of
the United Nations in 1947 contributed
to the end of outer key in Spain which
was not included in the master plan in
this way under the framework of our
global plan of control by the US against
communism against Paraguay and already
ascended European plan of city
regeneration the design of for Madrid a
business center further the possibility
of putting Spain back on the wall map as
it was in its imperialist imperialist
ages as the Spanish government changed
in 1951 that is with the appointment of
new ministers and other authorities the
country began to receive its first
economic aid from the United States
facing the paseo de la Castellana the US
Embassy in Madrid was laying under
construction between 1950 and 1955
planned by lalang King and errands
Warren and supervised by local market
Mariano Rodriguez the building was part
of an ambitious worldwide expansion of
international style US embassies as you
know future seats for a combined agenda
of propaganda and surveillance
in those years local architects were
inspired by the embassy and their
construction to the same freestanding
blocks surrounded by open garden public
spaces throughout the Spain a Madrid the
first Vienna for spano American art
imitating 1951 first show this approach
approach that was designed by the
architect and civil servant van Weyden
who knows monasterio as translation of
the Escorial style design by Lewis
Mallya this came from post three towers
and open spaces building buildings
organized symmetrically in a very
traditional fashion was it not this is
Kim modern enough for the grand
expectation of the authorities to come
to prison or rather were those
expectation I claim beyond a modern like
image I will return to this point later
in 1953 Spanish diplomatic and
geopolitical positions improve the
economic military agreements between the
US and spam name back to Madrid world
sign at the palacio de santa cruz in
madrid in odense chamber 22 26 1953 the
agreement power on the one hand the u.s.
in its anti-communist fight and on the
other hand the Spanish government in the
recognition of Franco's regime for the
u.s. that recognition was a lesser evil
in comparison with the audience of
consolidating the Atlantic block spain
kudo could do nothing but a set the
settlement of american defense bases in
exchange for economic and military
support for 10 years this aid came with
requests to substantially affect the
country's economic policy the concession
of American create of like the Spanish
government to take part in the u.s.
contention strategy against the Soviet
Union does Spain economic policy I
attended to local progress at the cost
of exposing the country as a potential
target for the
USS are with the general agreement on
tariffs and trade in 1947 and the Treaty
of Rome Europe became an ideal sing for
the promotion of public architectural
competitions European countries focused
not only on the construction of
institutional buildings as symbols of
Oran technical social and economic
renovation but also on the innovation of
international architecture conceived for
internally both internally for the
integration of Europe and externally
program for competitiveness in the
Western market similarly as paying I was
pursuing an image of modernity when
appealing enough to us to facilitate its
geopolitical relations with the West the
political and cultural opening of the
country in those years although is still
under control came through the
increasing circulation of publication
goods and foreign people as well as
through the travelling of many abroad of
many intellectuals but with regards to
the pursuit pursuit of modernity the
question remains as to what extent
authorities need with the introduction
of modern architecture organism this is
a collage made by by Fernando trika when
he came from Columbia University in 1953
he published his book on New York in
1954 a national architectural
competition was launched it for the Urim
plan of mandate business area conceived
as a vehicle for the menacing
modernization and nationalization of
Spain the governmental organization
technical office of the general
Commission for one planning of madrid on
its outskirts was in charge of
organizing the competition the
competition brief included the
formulation of a legal device for the
management of economic investment this
instrument was invented to promote
organization in the capital access on
December third in 1953 the lake st anna
was approved this law was aimed to to
secure the provo
of urban development different areas in
Madrid and was constituted as an
assistant to capture local investment
through contributing through
contributing with fiscal fees I specify
over the plot before being before being
in van nuys an hour build or through
making buildings and a quote by the
application of sense of physical
benefits as i said in the managerial
sense of oberlin la Castellana was the
immediate president of the land law of
May 12 1950s 56 the first zoning
regulation design in his pain in this
way the Ministry of government not only
established in the legal framework
linked it to this application of fiscal
benefits for the site of the competition
by the person straight arrangement pro
yet for the North East sector of avenida
de Generalissimo end of quote but also
this Avenue as the first Spanish
laboratory of the mutual promotion of an
international one development and
speculative real estate market this will
delete to the innovation of a financial
model linked to a land zoning to build
this a financial center authorities
would create their own bubble to secure
a constant flow of money to complete the
construction in a specific period of
time the competition conveying after the
appointment of Julian Laguna our cadet
and civil servant as a new president of
the general commission of Peruvian
planning and of Madrid on it and its
outskirts in may of nineteen fifty four
the draft program for the competition
was published in july 16 for Julian
Laguna the competition means an
extraordinary opportunity to advance
modern models of urban planning through
Madrid urban development but in order to
do so it demanded the largest
participation possible and above all a
special disposition which he puts thus
out to the sectional importance of this
commercial center which is which will be
the most outstanding of in the city in
the future within that giving the
to collaborate with the Commission in
this important mission is comment
convenient as much as the Spanish urban
planners would aim to take part in the
competition extending the presidency
itself in considerations regarding the
characteristics of competitions and the
purpose of that this one will be they
will be developed and judge with the
highest guarantees of impartiality so
that potential competitors can meet the
biggest motivation for this
collaboration which is granted fabric
favorably to them the previous version
of the this is the plot and in the in la
casa dianna the previous version of the
commercial center of 1951 didn't include
open participation in designing the
Mallik of the future or an agonistic
interesting collaboration in imagining
the most genuine modern go on
architecture for madrid a competition
was now sing as unnecessary instrument
to achieve the best design modernity
demanded competition the winning poet of
the competition by urban planner and
Tony Pena signify a critical saved in
the understanding and practice of omen
planning architecture in the capital
what were the mechanism he used to the
sign and win competitions as well as to
design his position he wants several
important achill important competitions
by doing and using his own archive an
archive which he completed with
traveling and photography well this is
deployed that one and in this in the
layout you can see that he was inspired
in the piazza san marcos of an asia with
a classic influence of camelot CT
another complex of aster buildings
concert Milewski
the models that were in the
publication's at the time well this is a
the cover of the nagising of these of
this commission of one planning a pundit
and this Rohit was incredible event
because was a and the only cat owner who
who participate and he one who want to
to design the great Madrid so was very
controversial and both materially nyan
and Catalan press/paul sighs it's a lot
the development where this is our
felicitations of padova Devore or your
bogus and carlos de miguel Pedregal you
know or a bogus did you know they were
almost made in the School of
Architecture metaluna propina was two
years older I think / an anchor jose
miguel was the editor of the magazine of
architecture on the central mallison ok
the development of the project well
these are sorry the developing of
deployed formatted second urban center
was dependent on the technical office of
the general Commission for one planning
of Madrid and its outskirts of like
bourbon yet to move from barcelona to
madrid in april of nineteen fifty-six
where he had been working as I were
planning at a technical officer of the
commission of my planning of Barcelona
since nineteen forty nine in a few years
he became a renowned architect after
winning important competitions
commissions and positions I am showing
here some of these competitions I'm
employed this was just after the he won
the competition of the commercial center
is the picture in the middle is the
ministry of industry commerce and
tourism and these are this is the model
of the United Nations and this is a
picture that he took when he came to New
York in 19 and 64 this is also a very
controversial project because was in the
in the same area as the project of
licorice here and they got cut back in
nineteen nineteen thirty one thirty
three and was the the city of sports and
a president of the Olympic Barcelona
this missing kind of one and he was well
this way was when / Pina I was part of
the team of Richard night Randy rare
buses and this is what it is he has a
lot of fluids but this is lee won the
last one I'm going to show you mrs. the
the US Embassy and this is an
intervention that he did he redesigned
the regulations for this part of LA
castellana erasing the old palace that
was in drawing he he wanted to spend the
the boulevard for the people to define
this public space as a representative
space for Spanish directory Maliki
Stanley the product of the competition
of 1954 which plan Porter was approving
on July tenth in 1957 aided by a
judicial framework that resolved Madrid
lands cloning complexities private
public distribution of land per minute
and want distribution of lying
investment to promote organization this
body washes issue it's a widely in Spain
and abroad in 1962 a new master plan of
Manila was directed by Papa Nia a Cell
revision of the plan whatever plan after
it was approved by the general
commission of one planning of Madrid and
outskirts and modest municipality in
1963 the business center plot of land
was legalized as well as they run
regulation for the management of its
development the business center was
defined as a rectangular area of 204,000
330 square meters attached to the coast
Dana access from noobs ministerios to
Pune to the Bernabeu santiago bernabeu
stadium the one incision of the business
center would bring in nineteen nineteen
sixty sixty seven parallel to these
developments the quantum arts foundation
proposed the to authorities the
promotion of the construction of an
opera theater and due to the complexity
of the network of investors known as and
according to the lamp low on the
constitution of public-private
urbanistic associations for urban
planning management odka was created I
was and depended all these people were
all these groups of interests were
partners in this association how to
interpret the public role of Ithaca
project and to what extent coat opinion
design his position as an intellectual
Afghanistan's to manage the group of
interest Sally the development of a
compensation system by means of a very
new land distribution which was
conceived as points system based Lance
value punto swallow swallow as it were
afforded remodeling some of those who
advertise Madrid's business center has
the most profitable business location in
the city where the same time
transforming into advantage consumer
side holders by knowing firsthand the
capitalization mechanism in spite of the
public information of any legal fiscal
natural organic news through official
bulletins with evolution of vodka its
activities in June of 1970 the
preferential agreement between Spain and
the economic european economic community
was signed in the same in the cement of
the same gear the Financial Times
published especially show on Europe
which included a report on the
successful progress of Spain towards the
european economic integration with
evolution of africa its activities and
speculative process between agriculture
the key living of volumes of the
priate of the competition they saved in
architectural representation well I was
from science 8ohm honest womanist
organism to the spectacular corporate
organism of steel and glass of his
skyscraper but it was not in the
original size of his view of a public
space for a city to build Democratic
wrong with in the capital of Spain ugly
as he put it his reflection on this
space or the original or reading of the
city in his document of the prior to be
approved in 1966 thank
ok Thank You Maria and now only Anna
Maria Leon thank you and thank you
Martin Murray and ayana for organizing
this great conference okay and I just
have to say it's been perfectly set up
with yesterday's paper on this earth and
now finish Maria finishing with that
quote so now we'll look at certain
although there is no record of the event
the protagonists of our story jose luis
held and paul lesser veena mighta first
met in the Paris international
exhibition of 1937 certain had just
escaped the Spanish Civil War leaving
behind a successful architecture career
and a celebrated pavilion for the
Spanish Republic highlighted this exile
German architect Paula cervino and help
with interiors of the u.s. pavilion one
of the several projects he did related
to the US government as a son-in-law of
US secretary of the Treasury henry
morgan hill after Paris Vienna assisted
Lucio Costa an Oscar Niemeyer endure
design for the Brazilian pavilion in the
New York's World Fair certain veena
would meet three years later in New York
City and i really like this picture
because I think they look a little like
Batman and Robin by then certain had
emigrated from Europe he had published
an on-set unsuccessful book and he had
failed to get a teaching offer from
Harvard he had exhaustion TCM
connections and needed a job winners
thighs to the US Department of State and
the South American avant-garde would
join certs credentials in the founding
of their firm town planning & Associates
TPA the union was blessed by the
seemingly divergent interest of the CM
and the US Department of State certs
mentor like Corbusier interested in
expanding the influence of the CM to New
Territories wrote to cert about vinners
connections in Brazil as a Spanish
speaker so it was ideally positioned to
work in South America not in Brazil but
this was only one of the reasons
certainty
I started looking south around the same
time winners father-in-law a key player
in world world to politics there he is
Henry Morgenthau introduced him to the
Secretary of State Gordo halt dinner and
Hall started a correspondence that
shaped the role winner insert would play
in post-war politics South America was
to play and understated but key role
through world world to it was
highlighted after the Pearl Harbor
attack which immediately prompted the
Pan American States Conference in Rio le
ha dado in January 1942 as a necessary
logistical step to cross the Atlantic
South America was quoted from both sides
of the conflict and had to struggle with
previous relations chile and argentina
had strong economic and military ties to
germany the main objective for the u.s.
in the video conference was to make the
severance of diplomatic relations with
the Axis powers of the guitar for all
Member States this was strongly opposed
by Chile and Argentina who feared
getting involved in a war of rival
imperialism's distrusted loyalty
declarations coming from the US the
final less forceful agreement mediated
by Brazil strongly displeased Cordell
Hull supervising from Washington in this
context we can real read halls influence
and winners comments on the necessity of
the u.s. to keep close to the southern
continent and the convenience of
influencing quote small but powerful
intellectual groups to this end vener
answered prepared a series of lectures
that were given in south america in 1942
45 and 55 financed by the department of
state with the specific stipulations of
delivering confidential reports and not
mentioning the source of their funding
their main destinations Brazil Peru and
Colombia located in the northern half of
South America were promising economies
that might help counter the influence of
the Southern Cone Chile and Argentina
held in the region we'll see how their
firm town planning & Associates related
to their political situations so what
I'll do is I'll trace three trajectories
and the trajectory of tea
or town planning & associates the firm
is in blue here we have a chronology
from 37 2 1960 and we're going to look
at Brazil and Peru as sort of briefly as
a context and I'll stay longer in the
plan for Bogota and then I'm going to
skip the nests whele and kuba and then
in yellow you have military
dictatorships of the extreme right in
South America so you see how they
overlap I will claim that tph work in
Latin America was instrumental in door
in their role in the CM supporting the
role in the CM and later for sir
becoming dean at Harvard i will also
argue that the fact that these plans
were never realized gave them their
value as political and architectural
currency as a promise of a modern utopia
so at the time Brazil was under the
dictatorship of hetalia Vargas who had
initially emulated the fascist
government of Italy and Portugal but
eventually decided to side with the
allies in the rio conference certain
winners first lecture in Brazil also in
the winter of 42 had perfect timing
Vargas has predilection for industrial
plants as a tool for fostering
nationalism and the large us investments
to bring the country over to the Allies
resulted in TPA is first Commission
Commission the city of motors the new
city he was meant to become a regional
center to help modernize agriculture in
the countryside Vargas who had chosen a
resilient team / le corbusier for a
previous Commission the Ministry of
Health would now favor foreign over
local replacing the original team of
saturnino Annie Meyer with me enhance
earth and niemeyer was furious in my of
course convinced communists was also
very eager to work for the fascist Italy
works this choice highlights the shift
in his government after World War two
products s government for the city of
motors the architecture detailed
architectural plans and sections well
the urban plans remain at a schematic
level the design was exceedingly
generous in the amenities it provided
for the workers probably too generous
for the Brazilian more urgent conditions
the good social intentions and
abstracted urban proposals of the
architects serve the more useful
political agenda in Vargas's government
modernity and rationality were put to
the service of the regime state built
social amenities were intended as ways
to control the behavior of the working
population and quote negate communist
promiscuity unquote these moves were
meant to counter Vargas's liberal
decisions and his acceptance of US
influence and money in the eyes of the
national mood that predominated in the
country in a way vargas was trying to
play both sides just as he had done at
the beginning of the world he is
negotiating both with Germany and the
u.s. he sends Hitler birthday card etc
journey was presented as a u.s. product
but one that served the fascist regime
in 1945 and you could led to changes in
government policy that ended any
possibility of realizing the project the
plan was now ready to fulfill a
different role in bridgewater for see on
six certain winners city of motors join
the caboose project for Sandy as the
argument of the cns real-life
applicability that through its
involvement with post-war reconstruction
and new city building the circumstances
that surrounded the Brazilian plan were
not part of the cm's narrative and were
left unsaid so as an aside after the
Brazilian plan falls through vener
divorced Alma Morganthau so he lost his
ties to the apartment of state but he
kept working for them and he married a
German artist that had just divorced a
hetalia varias s son gossip so now we go
to Peru TPS contact with us trained
architect Fernando Valley one day later
twice president Uhuru and right now an
influential figure close to the recently
elected government at this time
eventually resulted in the Commission
for the master plan of Chimbote team in
contrast to Brazil this contract was for
an existing population and to be done in
collaboration with local architects TPA
got started on the design in an
atmosphere of social chaos and political
uncertainty with the series of riots in
the suspension of civil liberties
brought on by the growing power of minus
alodia within the government soon our en
left
led a coup d'état and took over the
presidency the climax of the city series
of rapid shifts in the political
situation that were reflected in the
urgency of the architects design process
this accelerated pace was surpassed by
the rapid changes the town itself was
undergoing quickly exceeding TPAs
population growth projections due to
massive rural migrations the architects
kept working on the plan while the
government resume service of the foreign
debt and accepted substantial loans from
the World Bank and the IMF but the
strong nationalist mood of the country
soon view these moves as excessive ties
to the u.s. forcing other he had to
distance himself from his northern Ally
the precarious political situation
accessor baited by the weakness of the
peruvian soul to the US dollar made the
team but the plans economically
excessive and politically undesirable as
the prospects of the Chimbote the plan
disappeared from peru it's images became
useful in the nexium meeting convened in
italy in 1949 a conference that had a
particular emphasis in Latin American
projects cm7 was searched first Congress
as present as president he presented
three city projects Lima which was never
commissioned Chimbote a and tamaco a
small population in Colombia as a tactic
examples of CM urbanism and highlighted
how the chimp out the housing closely
followed local topologies incidentally
was convinced that he was following the
Spanish typology of patio he was unaware
that the specific double patio with no
lateral setbacks comes from Inca urban
Williams so this sort of imperfect
knowledge of vernacular but the attitude
of discovering what's existing and
showing it to the own population became
sort of characteristic of this very
uncomfortable relationship with in
modern local the great changes in scale
and housing technologies in sympathy in
contrast to the city of motors coincided
with TPS first extensive work under a
budget and down in collaboration with
South American architects although their
role has not been sufficiently
acknowledged one month after the
Congress Colombian architect Herbert
Witter met with cert winner and liquor
Gaussian cap Martin to formulate the
basic scheme of the architects Newcomb
the regulating plan of Bogota Colombia
so liquor buzios visit to Colombia in
1945 took place at the same time the
Colombian conservative party came to
power the discussions between the new
government and labor unions turn into a
period of confrontation and escalating
violence this was also the year of TPAs
first visit to Colombia although in this
case they were overshadowed by the swiss
architect and indirectly dismissed by
proa a Colombian architecture journal
presage Enda was too involved Colombian
Modern architects in the planning
process and bringing in the parousia to
sanction their work became almost an
obsession their campaign backfired since
the Courvoisier was anxious to get a
commission and associated himself with
TPA to work in Colombia so these are
ever more urgent telegrams from certain
winner to look over here saying if you
don't come we're not getting the
contract you have to come to order
certain dinner were set to fly back to
Colombia when they had to cancel because
of an unexpected and extremely violent
turn of events in directly related to
post-war international politics in 1948
the ninth inter-american conference took
place in Bogota the final in a series of
meetings that defined post-war relations
between the u.s. and South America while
the event took place or was taking place
the assassination of a liberal leader
prompted a series of extremely violent
riots in the day of destruction known as
elbow a tassel the riots attack symbolic
power structures including the seat of
the conference and the presidential
palace and burn down large parts of the
city the violence then turned to the
countryside causing massive migration to
the cities and creating an uncontrolled
urban expansion this is a quote and a
letter from Sara to dinner commenting on
the events says I hope everybody is okay
the next days will tell us if it's a
short revolt or a long civil war in this
case we can eliminate Colombia from her
agenda another experience time has told
that it was actually it was a long civil
war some people would say it's still
going on this period of extreme violence
seems to have our and that almost 10
years later that's his layout that
uses almost the same agua in the same
church right this period of extreme
violence seems to have increased the
messianic qualities attributed to modern
urbanism in both local and foreign
architects were eager to prove its
virtues in a 1949 edition of para on the
headlines one of the headlines claimed
firm ilysm is economy is happiness is
living with hope is like and it's
hygiene this plan was published in pro
in june nineteen forty eight and it
shows the damage done by the rides it
was presented as part of an urban
proposal done by colombian architects
which is was what bro i wanted right for
bogota and they say with the fires the
urban problem of owatta has been frankly
cleared and practically resolved and
this is liquid Lucia and TPAs plan for
the same area of valletta and you can
see how they're a very nice sort of
system of videos closely follows the
path of the fires actually the same
architect Herbert later was involved in
to both clans Colombian architect never
wither participate in this plan and then
was hired to be the Colombian
representative and the macabre catpa
team in 1947 a new law had been approved
which required city halls to collaborate
in city regard regulatory plans as a
consequence in the period after el
balazo TPA was working simultaneously on
the plans for the three most important
cities in Colombia however these legal
measures could do little against a huge
scale and shifting nature of the changes
the country was going through the
architects working simultaneously in
offices in New York parents and
bulletins we're in an almost impossible
situation they were charged with
planning cities that were in the midst
of a process of changing morphology and
very rapid growth it was a new monster
but if the plans were useless in the
long term in the short term they created
a semblance of government action and
order in a period of chaos the final
plan presented to a new government with
sympathies to Spanish fascism was
promptly accepted and made into law by
then it was obsolete role migration
surpassed the limits the architects had
fixed for the city
urban growth these problems required
fast and flexible solutions that were in
conflict with the rigidity of modern
planning and the bureaucratic
institutions that try to enforce it need
to resolve immediate problems let local
governments to open up roads that breach
the urban perimeter and to occupy
reserve zones established by the
architects so that while cert was
describing his plan as quote a realistic
finished proposal reality kept moving
further away from the image to plan had
been based on the fragile political
situation costly blur liberals and
conservatives to support a new coupe and
the new government soon took measures to
stop the violence that further
eliminated any prospects for the clans
realization by vinners last tour of
Latin America in 1955 the local
sentiment was that the plan had been
archived and both Vogel test growth and
Columbia's political situation were
drifting out of control in his final
report vina declared himself quote
rather disturbed by the political
situation finding that the oppression of
the government had resulted in fear and
a lack of interest in the promotion of
urban planning however as we have seen
the plan was unable to address urgent
urban problems not put aside in favor of
measures that were either more
convenient politically or more urgent
logistically the last two countries in
TPA sign American tour were Venezuela
and Cuba during the dictatorship of
Marcos Perez and fulton co Batista in
1953 after delivering the final version
of the Bogota plan turned headed to
Cambridge where he took over as dean of
the Harvard GST after his appointment
TPA wound up their work in Latin America
and the partnership ended almost
simultaneously with the dissolution of
the CM in 1960 so to recap when cert
begins his tour of the CM he had
basically never been commissioned for an
urban plan the Mesilla plan of Ursa Luna
was never commissioned he pitched it to
both governments in the right and left
but he never got a contract and he could
not get a job from the GSD he got a
letter suggesting he might get one to be
able to enter the US so at the end he
becomes team so the following quote to
conclude is from a letter
le corbusier commenting on the problems
of the Bogota plan voila in short this
is a story we know from experience how
long and complex it is to arrange for
more contracts no matter which country
in Latin America it is necessary never
to put too much confident in their
beautiful world works because they
forget them as soon as your airplane is
lost in the clouds search appointment as
dean of the GSD and the dissolution of
TPA coincided with the waning of us
interest in South America in the end the
Department of State indirectly help
finance the diffusion of modern planning
through both the outward image of us
expertise and the inner content of CM
organism for example in the extensive
press coverage that TP egg receipt
received in the South American press
their European origins one was trained
in Spain the other was training was a
German architect trained in Austria I
think we're never mentioned they were
consistently presented as expert us
consultants in this it actually says you
know very distinguished technicians from
the exterior representatives of the US
brand of urbanism that they knew little
about in contrast their work came to
represent the CM brand in the post-world
conferences and in journals in the US
and Europe and you can see there's a lot
of 53 publications the year that he
becomes the end of the GSD so this is
architectural forum and this is
detective the ugly and you can see the
emphasis on this being based on CM right
in the end the ultimate result of the
projects were their images they promoted
politically expedient ideas of
efficiency and modernity in South
America that were meant to help validate
the government's at sponsored them they
helped promote the work of TPA in the CM
in Europe and they give serta
credentials to become president of the
Congress and eventually dean at the GSD
the South American architectural
discourse with its blind faith in modern
urban planning initially participated in
the fiction that their future could be
outlined and the believe that the
boundaries of the discipline included a
capacity to change the state society and
capital but Walt EPA moved on to the
next Commission local architects had to
confront the futility of these
strategies and the inapplicability of
their ideas something they often argued
before the plans were completely in this
context TPA shared the failure of both
foreign architects at this period to
realize their plans in the midst of
political uncertainty but it is TPAs
inability to understand the conditions
that led to the obsolescence of their
plans or even acknowledge the changes
that were taking place and the political
roles their plans played the distance
system from the more critical role look
on our local architects play both local
and foreign architects were caught
between their desire for modernity and
the limitations of economic and
political crisis but as they were left
watching search plane local architects
had to face reality while the expert
consultants had the luxury of getting
lost in the clouds thank
hey well interesting indeed interesting
did to begin to begin this time to begin
again maybe this time with a friendly
challenge just to see where it might go
since I think there is a you know
sufficient let's say coherence in terms
of subject matter and I some extent in
terms of approach in or at least the
questions that are sort of circulating
within these three talks it seems it
seems possible let's say to test
something yeah so the friendly challenge
would be to invite you to consider the
term hegemony a term that I think again
needs to be sort of followed a little
bit and elaborated on
articulated in the context of this this
more general discussion we've been
having the hegemony not now in this case
though in two interrelated senses in one
sense hegemony of the state and hegemony
or stated Germany and the gentleman
hegemonies of capital you know so what
I'm essentially offering or to master
signifiers that having conditioned the
analysis of the interrelationships of
modernity and modernization again that
those the processes of modernization as
interacting with what I just called the
desire for modernity in all of these
cases in some sense so so what's lurking
behind that constellation seems to me is
that is the question of power and it's
you know this is not to equator Germany
with power in any linear and mechanical
sense but but to to sort of special file
a little bit what's at stake here US air
bases no roads to our institutional and
international and indeed incursions a
various in fact an encounter you could
say between between state control and
capitalist development in particularly
in the latter stages of the project that
Maria was this was presenting so okay
but but so part two of the sort of
meditation is to consider the thought
that specifically what a Germany means
or indicate or evidences in this cases
is something like a fact a fact about
power the power is homeless power in
this in both senses not just maybe the
more familiar sense of capital flows and
the sort of
trans national economies that they
support but in both senses of the
north-south exchanges for example that
that we just saw heard about between the
State Department and various dictators
the power as homeless it moves and in
that sense cannot be it's analytic it's
kind of its its understanding cannot be
confined to the sort of boundaries of
state state formations but then there
this this needs to be sort of attended
by the corollary question of if so and
in these concrete ways right it moves
across the ocean it moves with the air
bases but also is confronted in other
ways it enter interacts or dif different
sets of power relations encounter one
another what is it that moves power so
again there's a fork in the road 11 line
of thought might return to nature for
example and and insist the power itself
is in some sense in possession of a kind
of autonomy in kind of will another line
might attribute this kind of causality
to the two once one side of that
equation that I was trying to offer the
the sight of capital in other words that
capital is really what the capitalist
expansion is really what's driving overs
in any event we do in and through this
kind of concatenation of concepts and
processes we do arrive at something like
a problem of causality right you know
whether it is power the will to power a
kind of realtor kind of hegemonic little
that's that's driving all of this or or
whether it is capitals expansion in
which we wind up with an office complex
at the sort of tail end of this process
and so on that's driving things it seems
to me that we're compelled to ask what
is architectures role in this above and
beyond who the architects work for so
that's really what I'm you know how
wanna what I'm hoping that we can let
this sort of hit the ground so so in if
the client is not the configure for
causality for or indeed if the proper
name the proper name would be dictated
the proper name of the of the architect
of the kind of bearer of the the
heraldry of power is not let's say is
insufficient to account for this what do
you think in the detail sort of really
in the details might might be another
another place to look you know all of
you to respond to
which
well I don't know that I suppose we
should respond in order I don't know
yeah but I have I I think the idea of
the hedge money is is is very
interesting and very important
especially in the topic of the expansion
of the u.s. power abroad in the post-war
period and especially when we're talking
about US air force bases with your weird
we have a very clear example of the u.s.
building colonies on on foreign soil
these bases were essentially colonies of
American the American dream whether the
US air force or the US federal
government or Uncle Sam whatever
whatever euphemism you went to use for
the Americanization globalization
machine that was certainly present in
the nineteen fifty-six competition that
nature participated and whether the the
US air force was specifically saying we
want to build colonies on Spain I'm
guessing it was more Spain as it is a
strategical place for us to combat the
the advance of communism so and in that
particular case the US was very willing
to look sort of turn a blind eye to what
they did not agree with in terms of the
Franco regime it's very clear that the
u.s. government was not in agreement
with with the with the Franco regime but
they were willing to sort of let that
slide in order to gain the approval of
or to gain the foothold in the
Mediterranean interestingly enough
Franco was willing to look the was was
all very willing to accept that help
because it was sort of the replacement
for the Marshall Plan which which Spain
was not able to participate in at any
rate the important thing here is to say
whether there was or was not a hegemonic
intention by the part of the US
government for me the important part of
talking about moitra in this particular
situation is this to to clearly identify
that nitrogen monic idea unfortunately
in
many Spanish a historian circles there
there's an undercurrent of assigning to
nitra particularly and any other
American architect that came to the UK
miss fame as promoting that goal and I
think it's very important that we that
we don't assign that role to such
important figures as nature I for
example that the fact that he comes to
Spain not by the the invitation of the
US government the US Air Force any any
political movement here in the states
rather he comes by the invitation of the
very same Spaniards and by architects
not only in the nineteen fifty-six
competition also in his 1954 visit is
1969 visit every single time he comes to
Spain these sets foot in Spain it is in
a political manner so the question was
posed yesterday why do we and I can't
remember who posted why do we always try
to avoid charging the these architects
with political moves why do we always
try to let them be ambiguous and not
take a step in one direction or the
other the point is no etre was not
interested in the in the political
relationship between the US and Spain so
in this case we we leave him we allow
him to be an ambiguous figure because
that's what he / that's what he wanted
well you know I mean just to clarify a
little bit and for the benefit of others
also it seems to me that one of the
implications of my effort to reframe
this a little bit is is that it in a
sense it doesn't matter what he thinks
either way so I'm not you know I'm not
trying to indict moitra lemon on but nor
would you know this sort of innocence is
with madness what's at stake what's it's
because that's not how power works right
so
and it seemed to me that we are
responsible to that question precisely
to to work our way out of some of the
end games of innocence ideology critique
in the kind of first order sense in
other words a set of beliefs that are
articulated by architects that then
convene demystified what or not that's
first of all not anyway what ideology is
but but even even so but that's one
reason I wanted to use they don't like a
Germany which which in its different
let's say after lies post Graham she has
has typically been understood to operate
in a sense undercover under the cover
often of good intentions so you know
maybe that's a little bit of
clarification anyway I'm going to talk
about opinion because I didn't have a
chance in 20 minutes to talk about this
unknown person in the history of
architecture and spring / pina was
director of the commission of one
planning in Madrid I was informed by my
interviews very young people of their
active very first that the this
commission was work opinion the people
around him had more power than the
ministers of Franco because one planning
was a technical knowledge and to take
this is decisions they have all the
power to do the organism that they
thought was best for Puma driven so this
is a in one way but Prime but Papa Nia
wasn't inside the the thing or the
rating as it was with a lot for example
so Pina was a person not ambiguous I
think he Selena was very clear from the
beginning
also I didn't have a chance to talk
about his background in Barcelona and
also he was born in Iran and cetera he
was in between he was I mean he was a
dreamer of being an architect and and
doing architecture and and doing new
things and opening flows of
communication with other mates in Europe
and the states I mean I think they the
general mood of poppy Nia was he was a
friend of he was his disposition was a
friendship who is he friends with ya
what he was at the beginning friends of
the Catalans at the beginning okay he
came he went to Madrid and Madrid no
material Amiens didn't life didn't like
in basehor a Catalan invader in Madrid
so yes he was he was in between yeah but
i guess where i was you know only
wondering too I mean this was at the
integer moni about the urban planning
and how well this is one thing that was
it's not you I mean it's not ready money
as as we can understand the Franco's
regime completely there were people that
was not right Oh beans but in that you
in a sense of have very neatly
demonstrated one of my implications
which is to say that that the figure of
the technocrat and this is also i think
in anna's concluding comments made clear
that the figure of the technocrat
potentially and this kind of complex of
architecture urban planning is it you
know it can operate as an age and
particular you know cuz in that sent a
simple answer to the question you see
friends we he's a friend of capital but
not you know as a banker per se as a
kind of agent of the banks but
rather as an agent of the kind of forms
of I hesitate to say rationalization
because I think that's another one of
these sort of fetish words like
Americanization that needs to be
unpacked but but let's just say that you
know that that this agent of expertise
in the guise of you know of friendship
and expertise that that interview know
in other words what sink fascinating
about the the story that you tell is is
the encounter between totalitarianism
and maybe shall we not say encounter but
let's say the friendship between
totalitarianism and corporate capitalism
and so and so democracy and you know
that the thing that is in your title
seems to occupy a troubled place in this
relationship but maybe that's a part two
of a different question right well I
just wanted to say that what was so
interesting to me instead of doing the
research for this paper was the
unexpected surprises and in how power
was in the places I at least expected it
to to be right so you would think Hugh
huge sort of us powerful country owner
of capital right and he's poor little
countries but activates the
dictatorships in South America at the
time were very fragile very moving but
when they were in power their power over
the country was more absolute
the power the US could have so there is
the shifting nature this capital that's
influencing what they want to do so
there then subject to capital and to the
US and then at the same time they have
to attend to a shifting population that
even if it's a dictatorship the
population is shifting and there's a
nationalist mood and you see sort of the
pattern repeat itself where no matter
how much money the u.s. is sort of
either over the world bank or the IMF is
throwing into these countries the
population is an unrest the dictator
just basically says okay I have if I
want to stay in place I have to stop to
this capital and to attend to my
population so suddenly the architect is
to fire basically right there disengage
it goes away and I was also surprised by
the lack of agency from his European
architects coming in I would think they
would be in a very powerful place at the
same time and then reading the
correspondence they were actually quite
desperate to get these commissions yeah
well there's an interesting footnote to
this out as I'm you know as we invite
questions from the audience as well that
but which which imply maybe by extension
thats Sarah in his flexibility mm-hmm is
a kind of post modernist a kind of early
post modernist and in very specific ways
I mean in in other words you know
another name for this sort of practice
would be in a sense post ideological you
know it's not so much that he and I
don't think there's that much evidence
in the Telegraph's on that he's like
identifying but that's the thing about
being in the clouds it's like he's not
really wanting to be on any
exactly as a technocrat and then how
this is again a connection as a
technocrat he is he and weiner our
understanding themselves at least and
and presenting themselves publicly as as
above like the in the clouds above the
clouds of Audiology mattia manifest
ideology party musicians and so on so
you know that can simply be understood
as cynical or opportunist but but if
there's something structural about your
chart in the end there's a tendency
towards harvard shall we say you know
one of the headquarters of the labor
force motors developments the you know i
would be tempted to sort of follow that
that lead a little bit you know not
stylistically per se but in a sense of
this the kind of underlying
relationships between architecture power
and capital that that we you know that
we're discussing so so you know and that
just to conclude this comment it that
would seem to complicate the idea that I
think it's more evident in the case of
both the way you presented noite rebetol
so it's it's like I've lurking there
with certain vena that you know of these
architects and planners as bearers of
modernism / modernity you know this in
stylistic terms yes in let's say
histological terms maybe yes also
because the organization of territory
and the design of buildings are
integrated etc but when articulated with
this this question
and the you know there's a little bit
more at play there than simply the kind
of let's say idea the architect as a
representative of an international
technocratic practice that floats above
the clouds so in any case that maybe we
could and I think along those same lines
there's an important we need to make an
important distinction between perception
and reality we're talking about hegemony
because in the case of noise or in the
case of search during the case affecting
add to the there could be any number of
ways that the Spanish or the Latin
American public would perceive that
action which in regardless of what the
motives of any one of these three people
would be the perception of those motives
can be complied completely different so
I think there's an important distinction
there that needs to be drawn in terms of
perspective perception reality and there
would be different archives to test all
that they said you'd study different
things and exams are these questions so
anyway ok let's just see oh k 12 Michael
well ok let's look at we have a job and
my goal can I just say that this paper
was written for its ok well no reasoning
no no it shows we should I just want to
thank you it's it's a it's a product was
trying to make it quicken everyone again
just to follow up on the question of
hegemony and power I mean one way to
address the question of power is to
articulate the idea of the subject that
power needs a subject to make its
exercise intelligible it doesn't it
cannot operate in a vacuum so and that
subject that doesn't need to be
hegemonic or you know monolithic it's
bifurcated it's you know could be
contradictory it could be multiple it's
a modern subject it could be
articulation or different ethnic
minorities so what do you think in your
different projects were the subjects of
the you know
or imagine subjects which can give then
each mode of power help us articulate
and give it a different texture I always
had the feeling looking at these plants
that they always seemed so detached that
it seems the subject is not the real
citizen in a way but a constructed
fabrication that will be pliable to
modern modernism that will function to
avoid this communist promiscuity so it
seems like the subject is made up by the
architects by the state and they're all
participating that believe that these
plans will work and that's one subject
and the other subject is basically it's
irrelevant who's going to populate these
plants the more important audience is
the people that are going to look at
them as great improvements right
modernity arriving hi I have a question
about your question about power so in
imposing this question of power it seems
to me like there's there's something in
specifically on Maria's paper that to
some extent there's a different theme
that kind of gets you out of that
question in a certain way rather than
talking about who has power in this
relationship between that's a client an
architect or between governments and
architects that work for them it seems
like you could also ask which domains of
power or power within which networks on
the idea that there are multiple
networks of power and there's a question
about how they intersect with each other
and so it seemed to be the part
specifically not a Maria's paper a part
of what was being unpacked there was
about how a certain discourse network of
architects and urban planners and power
structures that operate their intersects
with the power structures of
capital and urban plans and about how
each have members within each domain can
be quite strategic in drawing giving
specific utility to the other in a
strategic way that lets them draw power
that then they can apply within their
own network and so the narrative absurd
how he his progression through CM and
then all the way to Harvard it seems to
me that I'm not so sure you could
describe it as postmodernist in that
sense it seems to me quite strategic and
rather than describing him as being
loose or flexible you could describe as
being agile and strategic in a way that
is quite modernist that liqueur PCA for
example also shares that same kind of
agility in giving a specific utility
within another broader power network in
order to gain a certain currency within
a power network that then can be applied
that has to do with you know kind of
professionalized architecture discourse
network for example and in Reverse you
know members of these governments are
drawing on architects and urban planners
and giving them a specific utility in
order to gain certain kinds of currency
in their own power network so it seems
to me that it's a different way of
framing the question that's not so much
it gets out of the kind of what I think
is a kind of standard question of you
know does the architect have agency are
not in relationship to government ality
another name for your another figure
there would be Philip Johnson
yeah definitely certainly strategic
certainly taking from different networks
I thought it was very interesting how
the liquid which he was so interested in
launching cert on to South America to
have a connection and to sort of force
those relationships in to see em at the
same time once he's working there he's
actually not that interested in he's
making contact with local architects
sort of feeling off into that Network to
to sort of get commissions but at the
same time he's not so interested in
pursuing local chapters of CM and
bringing them back to to those here
meetings so I think another interesting
way to look at this I the discussion of
power and hegemony is to introduce the
third third synonym of authority and i
think the word authority allows us to
look at different types of authority
power it seems to be very to me to be
very one-sided and one person has power
over another pop another person but when
we talk about authority there are many
different ways that one person exercises
authority over another person and it
seems like in the three cases here we're
talking about a mentor relationship
rather than a dictator relationship and
I'm speaking specifically to say it
nitra and Becky Nia or perhaps the case
of capitalism in paragraph or or
business infecting yacht in this in in
the in the sense that there is an agenda
has an agenda moitra has an agenda but
the agenda is to prove to the people in
these countries that yes modernism is
possible where you are I completely
agree no well I don't think he was that
interest I want to clarify that cert
Hannibal's arts training when he gets to
Bogota the school of architecture in
Bogota was founded i think in 36 was
modern from the start and had little
mozarts training the architects that
he's dealing with our train
historic in Peru is trained at MIT for
another way lawanda also trained in the
united states that director of pro i was
trained in France so the local
architects were actually sort of outrage
that they had this person being branded
as an expert they were actually more
modern we will train their modern since
they were babies baby architects right
they didn't have this conversion that
said yes so this is why provides so
outraged when local Mussina gets the
Commission because they wanted to do the
point he basically said you know okay so
there was no need to convince
architecture to be modern no no I I
guess I say that we answered what what
sir wanted was to get commissions right
and have something to show because
otherwise he would have been an
unemployed architect basically all
through that time I don't think you
would have been a good convincing
president for this young if he would
have said you know I'm just hanging out
here in New York mm-hmm sorry I guess
what I wanted me to say that it seems
like that was the that was the
perception of moisture or certain not
the perception necessarily the
perception of those that were listening
to them that the the mentor relationship
was was was the idea of nitra or the
idea of said and whether it was accepted
or not is another question mentor to to
whom it the the idea of being a mentor
was held specifically by nature that or
by certain and whether he was accepted
as a mentor is a difference we should
I just want to say that perpignan in the
developing of odka he was the architect
of the private sector she wasn't
engaging the public my part cut above
part was in the ministry and all these
the people of the Caribbean he wasn't
interested in the capitalist organism he
was doing organism as he was doing other
kind of urban planning in Spain this was
only one probe his longest Freud but he
lives morton's thority has exerted
itself I know I there there is it
there's a power struggle going on in the
audience Richmond who has the mic and
who has the his hand I should allow you
to ask you a question and then Patricio
you can as and then we'll answer
together then we'll finish there yeah I
think your hegemony really is policy
I've been working on morgenthau that's a
son a lawyer tajima Morgan tall leather
leather Lisa to battle that was the most
important battle in the history of the
20th century and what we're doing here
is we're giving you money you give us
geography that's gonna be like that
that's the mentality and it really is
important and it's not a secondary
thought that he also was appointing the
Maritime Commission heads he got Kennedy
in there before he got the SEC etc trade
navy FDR Navy's the big thing trade and
then we're talking about South America
how can you miss it Brazil is the whole
coast of the Atlantic Ocean and to say
the other thing Lima Peru and Colombia
absolutely so I think that was a policy
decision again maneet not so hot he had
him walking through a plan for a year
and a half that stopping the Germans get
rid of that Japan let MacArthur a
general decide what to do not exactly a
you know national consensus about how we
handled something as important as that
and you can see the failures and the
missourian question yeah that's what did
I make yeah okay now that makes sense I
don't I think probably
but just to complicate more the issue if
you can this seems to be a shift between
talking about architecture through
culture and now and talking about
architecture through technology the I
think one of the important relationship
that's missing because it actually
completes the triangle between United
States Spain and Latin America is that
the Franco regime establishes very
strong ties with the parent regime
precisely through the Biennale Arctic
solely on cultural grounds and it is the
cult they talk about poster on the
defense's Hispanic culture precisely
after the war when they see themselves
as completely separate this seems to
become an abandonment of culture in in
the pro this technocratic taking or the
technological transformation of the
architect which is also then suffered
through certain house early is actually
then sort of portray to try to portray
in Latin America there seems to be in
this company this protein a problem of
power a key figure that is missing in in
the examination of Latin America which i
think is the figure of the economist I
will put a week because right now and
despaired the big whole region is
precisely extract for cash and it is the
assembly of an alternative version to
the United States because the United
States to complete it has this its aims
on Europe that seems to then
reassembling the architectural field in
Latin America and I wonder if you
actually are again have considering this
dichotomy between culture and the
technology but also if you are
considering of examining or introducing
the figure of povitch inter of the mix
maybe we'll have to allow both of these
comments which I think in fact are
related to one another to have the last
word you don't worry as as sort of
open-ended suggestions and
and continue we're only 20 minutes
behind that's not bad so but in the you
know kind of interest of catching up we
will reconvene in five minutes again as
we did yesterday and I think it'll be
fine okay thank you again should we
continue